très bien la parole est ensuite à
Monsieur Bernard Delcourt pour l'Union
centriste
et pour 4 minutes
bien sûr le président
monsieur le ministre cher collègue au
travers de son programme de stabilité le
gouvernement affiche un objectif de
réduction du déficit public ramené à
2,7% du PIB d'ici 4 ans et un ratio
d'endettement public à 108,3%
sans ambiguïté notre groupe partage
votre objectif de réduction du déficit
et de diminution de notre dette
avec moins de 40 milliards d'euros en
2021 plus de 50 milliards en 2022 et 70
milliards à l'horizon 2027 la facture
annuelle de remboursement de notre dette
s'envole et nous en connaissons les
raisons et dans ce contexte la poursuite
de la dégradation de nos comptes publics
ne peut pas être une option
mais pour nous la trajectoire le
calendrier et les solutions pour
redresser nos comptes publics doivent
prendre en compte plusieurs impératifs
première réalité aujourd'hui 20% de
dépenses de l'État sont gâchés par une
loi de programmation qui prévoit une
montée en puissance des crédits
budgétaires de plusieurs ministères
c'est une réalité
deuxièmement le redressement des comptes
publics ne peut en aucun cas se faire au
détriment des services publics
essentiels dans l'État doit être garant
tant de leur qualité que d'un égal accès
de tous nos concitoyens je pense
notamment à la santé l'éducation ou
encore la justice qui appelle des moyens
importants troisièmement le redressement
des comptes publics ne peut pas se faire
au détriment des investissements qui
sont absolument nécessaires pour réussir
la transition écologique et
technologique comme celui de la
souveraineté de la France et de l'Europe
dans des secteurs stratégiques
quatrième impératif la trajectoire
budgétaire doit aussi intégrer les
besoins des collectivités territoriales
dans l'action et fondamentale pour
garantir les équilibres sociaux
économiques du pays
il ne veut pas se faire non plus
permettez-moi de l'ajouter au détriment
de l'avenir du monde rural qui nécessite
la mise en oeuvre d'une politique
d'aménagement du territoire volontariste
il s'agit donc bien de réussir à
conseiller l'objectif de redressement
des comptes avec ses impératifs de
dépenses et notre groupe considère que
cette équation ne peut pas reposer
uniquement sous la réduction de la
dépense publique le levier des recettes
doit aussi être actionné c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que nous allions
proposé une contribution exceptionnelle
de très grandes entreprises ayant
réalisé des profits exceptionnels pour
financer les mesures liées à la crise
c'est aussi pour cela que nous
approuvons sans réserve votre plan de
lutte contre toutes les fraudes qui bien
menées pour régénérer plusieurs
milliards d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires de même je pense qu'un
travail de fond en direction des niches
fiscales doit être engagée rapidement
elle représente aujourd'hui près de 90
milliards d'euros plus du quart des
recettes de l'État et notre groupe fera
des propositions dans ce sens d'autres
pistes de recettes supplémentaires
pourraient d'ailleurs être envisagée
vous l'aurez compris monsieur le
ministre nous considérons qu'une coupe
systématique de 5% dans les budgets de
tous les ministères de manière uniforme
ne peut pas être la solution car elle ne
permettrait pas de répondre aux besoins
du pays ainsi nous devons trouver un
équilibre entre maîtrise la dépense
publique et c'est nécessaire
optimisation des rentrées fiscales il le
faut et une politique de l'État au
rendez-vous des enjeux et des besoins du
pays tel est pour notre groupe le défi
que doivent relever les textes
financiers à venir et nous y apporter